welcome to this video playing nakato
from Cuba right yes let's see nims Oh
bloomfeld's Kings Indian Kings Indian
yeah Kings Indian what should I play
against the Kings in yen hmm ok maybe
maybe the other buck is one of my old
favorites simply because black players
some quite often don't have a good
recipe against it hmm maybe maybe this
is one of the positions where you can go
h4 h5 it's a very dumb very difficult at
times in this opening to judge when this
is possible or when it's it's not
helping maybe here I can I can do that i
guess ii 5s plex reply a 5d 595 and then
f3 babe probably now this is
probably a play the line okay 96
brilliant okay I mean if I if I say hey
I probably should continue with the with
the attack if there's a German figure of
speech of you say a you should also say
beep is there something that's probably
something similar in English in English
okay it's bishop h6 possible now or is
this just too too much that's probably
too much but this is not a bad move i
mean what is the night doing only six
they are probably supporting c5 i was
just about to say that the only only
real justification okay this is probably
necessary now and he can put it on d4 of
course okay so long castles and Bishop
h6 not much else of course this will get
very sharp like if I if I wasn't black
shoes I would just play beehive here
instantly and tear open the Queen side
ok yeah this is also a vented choice
very very valid choice hmm yeah
I don't cannot accept this night to be
there forever okay visual basics let's
let's continue him he might play capture
here I kept you on c4 but Sam it's more
important I believe to get this a tech
going on them on the kingside this h4 h5
really needs to be justified maybe
that's not not so bad yeah this is
surprising okay didn't expect him to to
allow that okay I need how to play mmhmm
yeah the very strong night okay I hope
let's first take you will flame like a
six or queen f5 problem down yeah what
now the slight only form that take a 590
form added maybe I should have done that
anyway
okay blood forfeits due to disconnection
ah what the heck no in this position
noble oh what a shame ah come on yeah
yeah I'm still going to post the game
what a shame but it's such an
interesting game interesting position I
don't think I'm in good shape here but
it's it's so sharp okay I went let's
let's see him I went I went for you
maybe I should like quickly quickly go
back a couple of more so here this is
probably necessary c5 ok thanks ok maybe
there are alternatives taking first I
didn't want to oops deal with the before
threat this also seemed seem tricky to
me let's say after this move but ok I
can he can play that nothing better ok
well I wanted to take anyway it takes a
six not sure that's also Queen a five
almost like that takes and now I'm f
takes computers really long as cool as
ever taking and taking a six maybe maybe
if this night is doing a good defensive
job ok I played a different move I plate
after this I played lady five and then
he disconnected the idea of this move is
that after takes I mean this is probably
forced this my idea was to play
something like that if I've was clearing
the e4 square but he has rook a seven
this is very strong actually yeah no
this is not not working at all whites
whites idea so very lucky that he
disconnected but also very unlucky
because it's it was a very interesting
position however here I wasn't
necessarily am committed to play 94
immediately and also the capture I
actually thought that maybe am I have
this in reverse and as a reverse in
reserve so I can play it later maybe
this one and then this this kind of
ideas yeah it's still very murky but if
I've was wasn't a good idea probably am
I should just really take g 6 & a 6
probably i have very complicated stuff
yeah a shame that you disconnected
really in the middle of this this fine
ok thanks for watching anyway